a peaceful end to an hours-long hostage
crisis in the heart of the lebanese
capital bassam hassan laid down his gun
and left the bank escorted by security
forces after a deal that gave him back
some of his money like millions of
lebanese hassan has not been able to
access his account since lebanon's
financial crisis took hold nearly three
years ago where is my right where is my
money i worked and many many many
millions of lebanese people they worked
abroad they worked in the lebanese
economy they saved their money they put
them in the bank the legal they are not
with us the politics is not with us the
banks is not with us
outside his relatives friends and
depositors gathered to show support to a
man they say has been driven to the
brink and had no other choice
witnesses say the armed men visited the
bank several times in recent days
demanding five thousand dollars from his
account to pay for his father's hospital
bill the bank refused to give him the
money
banks imposed limits on withdrawals in
dollars and withdrawals in the local
currency are at a rate far below the
market price a significant cut in the
original value of deposits
thursday's standoff is not the first of
its kind in january a depositor withdrew
fifty thousand dollars from his account
after holding bank staff hostage he
spent a few weeks in jail many feel they
are paying the price for the financial
collapse
i have some money for my daughter for
the school
sometimes i ask money for the schools
for my friends
but
i worked more than 30 years didn't give
from my money even 200
banks have been major lenders to the
government for decades they say they are
not at fault blaming politicians for
mismanaging the economy but people know
many politicians are bankers and they
have been protecting themselves instead
of taking action to reverse the economic
collapse senator al-jazeera beirut
lebanon has been in a deep economic
crisis since 2019. the united nations
says nearly 80 of its people are living
in poverty the lebanese currency has
lost more than 90 of its value
devastating for a nation that imports
most of its goods international donors
say aid is conditional on reforms which
politicians have so far resisted
rayet hawi was lebanon's economy
minister up until 2019. he told me the
severe financial crisis is paralyzing
the country
banks and banks employees are also
victims of the government corruption
lack of decisions and
mismanagement over the last 30 years
you know that the government has
defaulted
on its debt and
also
the government has took the money from
the central bank by loans and they did
not return it back
to the channel whereby they took the
depositors money force of the
politicians who
mainly took the money to subsidize
certain products to subsidize the uh
the over
recruitment in the public sector to
subsidize the fixing of exchange rates
over the last 30 years that created an
artificial purchasing power for the
people who were asking for foreign
reserve and the only
thing they have been doing is
depleting the liquidity from the
people's deposits through the central
bank and down through the the the banks
so this uh over the years the government
has mismanaged the money of the people
and i totally understand the anger of
the people and however these people
should go
and
you know protest against the government
and against who really may took their
money and who really spend their money